To many, Nikola Tesla was a genius, unappreciated
in his own time.
Born in the Austrian Empire in 1856, the Serbian
American inventor was arguably one of the
most brilliant minds of his day, and yet Tesla
never reached the level of fame and acclaim
that he perhaps deserved.
For those of you who are unfamiliar with his
work, Nikola Tesla was a mechanical and electrical
engineer, best known for his contributions
to the designs for what would become the modern
alternating current electricity supply system,
or “AC.”
It was Tesla’s hope that he could patent
and sell his inventions, that the creations
and advancements he made would help to improve
the lives of everyday people.
Unfortunately, due to the ruthless and callous
business practices of his rival, Thomas Edison,
much of Nikola Tesla’s work faded into obscurity
after his death in 1943.
However, what if one of his inventions was
not only a success, but proved so deadly in
its intended function that it had to be contained?
And who better to keep something like that
secured than the experts in anomalous entities,
objects, and technology: The SCP Foundation.
Meet the Teleforce, one of the surviving inventions
of Nikola Tesla’s legacy, better known to
our friends at the Foundation as SCP-2700.
While most information about various anomalies
is kept secret by the Foundation through the
use of memory altering drugs called amnestics,
SCP-2700 may be one of the few anomalies that
the public is aware of.
Or at least, they might be aware of the proposed
concept of the Teleforce.
Tesla himself described the invention as a
type of weapon that would fire pellets or
rounds of material.
However, rather than acting like a conventional
firearm, the Teleforce would launch these
projectiles at high velocity from inside a
vacuum chamber, using electrostatic repulsion
to fire these rounds at the intended target.
This probably sounds like a weapon pulled
straight from early works of science fiction,
but Nikola Tesla claimed that it was an idea
that came to him after he studied the Van
de Graaf generator.
It was Tesla’s hope that his Teleforce could
be used as a defensive weapon that could either
be deployed against enemy infantry on ground
level, or even be fired at aircraft with enough
power to bring them down.
However, word of this invention soon got out
to the public.
In 1934, a number of New York newspapers referred
to the Teleforce using the fear mongering
description of a “death ray.”
Whether this was just a misunderstanding or
done to incite mistrust in Tesla and his work,
it forced the inventor to address the matter
publicly, saying:
“This invention of mine does not contemplate
the use of any so-called 'death rays.'
Rays are not applicable because they cannot
be produced in requisite quantities and diminish
rapidly in intensity with distance.
All the energy of New York City transformed
into rays and projected twenty miles, could
not kill a human being, because, according
to a well-known law of physics, it would disperse
to such an extent as to be ineffectual.
My apparatus projects particles...”
As for the device itself?
Well, the SCP Foundation was able to uncover
a seemingly perfected version of the Teleforce
in 1946, three years after Nikola Tesla’s
death.
Found in an abandoned research facility believed
to have been used by Tesla himself, SCP-2700
seemed to be the weapon that the Serbian inventor
had described.
It was only when the SCP Foundation began
to take a closer look at the device that their
researchers realized something.
SCP-2700 could have been even more dangerous
than Tesla had intended the Teleforce to be
in his original designs for the weapon.
The device itself is made from three main
components.
First is the interface, designated SCP-2700-1.
This is a metal console, complete with a qwerty
keyboard and a display screen, along with
a number of buttons, switches, dials and levers,
each responsible for controlling a key aspect
of SCP-2700.
SCP-2700-1 features a command based operating
system, with any command typed on the keyboard
appearing on screen in green block text.
The Foundation is still baffled as to how
an engineer like Tesla, even one as gifted
as he, was able to create an operating system
like this with the limitations of technology
during the early 1940s.
A network of conductive copper wiring then
connects the SCP-2700-1 control console to
the other two components of SCP-2700, appropriately
known as SCP-2700-2 and SCP-2700-3.
Foundation researchers tasked with examining
and understanding the Teleforce believe the
SCP-2700-2 part of the device to be a particle
accelerator.
Now, it’s hard to go into exactly how particle
accelerators work in this video, but we’ll
do our best to keep it short and simple.
Like the name suggests, a particle accelerator's
job is to increase the speed of subatomic
particles like protons or electrons.
Basically, particle accelerators create a
beam of these particles that have been charged
to hold extremely high amounts of energy,
and these charged particle beams are often
useful for a number of different scientific
research methods.
That’s what the big particle accelerator
up at CERN is used for.
This one, SCP-2700-2, on the other hand is,
well, it’s not for research per se.
It’s held securely in a lead-lined tungsten
chamber, in the shape of a cylinder.
Although it contains all the parts you’d
expect to find in a modern day particle accelerator,
SCP-2700-2 is a lot smaller at just 7.35 meters
long.
Then, we get to SCP-2700-3, the core of the
Teleforce.
Also composed of lead-lined tungsten, it is
a spherical frame with an apparatus inside,
visible through a silica glass porthole on
one side.
Within this outer sphere is another, smaller
sphere frame, that was built using an unidentified
material.
According to notes that the Foundation has
recovered, Tesla himself wrote that the space
inside this sphere is held in a perpetual
vacuum state.
But what is perhaps most interesting, and
concerning, about SCP-2700-3 isn’t the metal
frame itself, but rather what is held inside
of it.
Glowing at the center is the fourth and final
component of Teleforce, known only as SCP-2700-Omega.
This, as far as the best minds of the SCP
Foundation can tell, is the power source of
the weapon.
It is an anomaly in and of itself, a phenomenon
of energy that does not behave within the
normal laws of physics.
Specifically, SCP-2700-Omega directly contradicts
what is known as entropy.
Due to these abnormal properties, the space
within SCP-2700-3 containing SCP-2700-Omega
does not obey standard rules of time.
The flow of time within the power source’s
chamber seems to be reversed somehow.
However, researchers have noted that the frame
and inner sphere of SCP-2700-3 that surround
SCP-2700-Omega seem to be unaffected by these
anomalous effects.
It is because of this power source that SCP-2700
is even more dangerous than Nikola Tesla would
have ever intended.
Never mind the fact that the Teleforce weapon
was designed to fire super-charged high velocity
rounds at a target, the sole component powering
it could prove to be devastatingly destructive
itself, if it ever broke out from within its
frame.
According to predictions and calculations
made by the SCP Foundation’s top scientific
researchers, if SCP-2700-Omega was ever to
be released or accidentally break free from
the SCP-2700-3 apparatus that contains it,
then the result would be catastrophic.
The power source’s anomalous properties,
resisting the laws of physics and time themselves,
would cause a massive chain reaction.
The rest of the universe would be converted
to the same inverted state of entropy that
SCP-2700-Omega exists in, which would ultimately
lead to a YK Class Entropic Annihilation Event.
The whole universe as we know it would be
pulled inwards, creating an infinitely energetic
singularity.
In short, it would be the Big Bang but in
reverse, with all of creation pulled inside
out.
The worst part of all of this?
According to the read-outs on SCP-2700-1’s
display monitor, the Teleforce has been armed.
Counting down, the weapon is scheduled to
activate in the year 2234, exactly three hundred
years after being armed, most likely by Tesla
himself.
If the device was to ever fully activate,
SCP-2700-Omega would be breached, and the
entire universe could be unraveled and sucked
into a singularity.
The only hope the SCP Foundation has of preventing
this destruction, is to destroy or contain
SCP-2700 within another SCP.
The O5 Council are still searching for a suitable
candidate should the worst come to pass.
For now, personnel have been instructed to
avoid tampering with the Teleforce in any
way, shape or form.
Should SCP-2700-Omega show any change in its
behavior, then let’s just hope that the
Overseer Council is able to produce an anomaly
capable of neutralizing it.
But there’s still one other big question
that needs answering.
Namely, how on Earth did Nikola Tesla, a scientist
limited by the technology of his time, create
a power source like SCP-2700-Omega?
Something with the capability to unravel the
entire universe if it ever breached its containment?
Well, the man himself may have given us the
answers.
The SCP Archive’s file on SCP-2700 concludes
with an extract of a log that Nikola Tesla
kept during the last decade of his life.
As was mentioned before, Tesla was not exactly
a success in his own time.
He chose to keep trying to produce his inventions
despite driving himself towards financial
ruin.
He was the Vincent Van Gogh of science.
Depression took a hold of the inventor in
his later years, until one day he was approached
by a mysterious figure.
This man, as it turned out, was a traveler
from another universe, and brought Tesla with
him to this alternate reality.
In his log book, Nikola lamented over how
discontent he was with his life in our universe,
and how transcendentally beautiful it was
in this new one.
While there, Tesla worked with a group of
fellow scientists, all brought to that universe
by the same traveler, with the goal of creating
a source of perpetual energy.
This power source was intended to break the
known laws of thermodynamics, and it seemed
that SCP-2700-Omega itself was the outcome
of these scientific minds coming together.
By combining two substances from two universes
with completely different laws of physics
to our own, Tesla and the others created the
power source they had dreamed of.
But things quickly started to go wrong.
Tesla realized that the core, later known
as SCP-2100-Omega, was somehow moving backwards
in time.
As he tried to correct it, he realized the
device had been locked, and that someone had
armed it.
Why?
The traveler revealed that this was his plan
all along, to create something capable of
destroying this universe.
It turned out, the alternate universe he had
brought Tesla to was not the traveler’s
home, rather a different place he wished to
destroy with the singularity that SCP-2700-Omega
would cause.
The traveler vanished to his true home, leaving
Nikola Tesla alone with SCP-2700.
Saddened to think his invention would destroy
this new universe, which he found to be profoundly
beautiful, he made a truly unexpected decision.
He returned home, and in his sadness, thought
it would be better if the device he’d helped
create brought about the end of our universe.
SCP-2700 is now a ticking time bomb, destined
to wipe out our entire reality unless the
device can be disarmed or otherwise neutralized.
All this, set in motion by a scientist long
dead, who submitted all of us as an unwilling
sacrifice for a universe we’d never know.
Or perhaps this was done as an act of revenge
for his own lack of success and appreciation
in life, one final act to make sure that if
he wasn’t remembered, no one else would
be either.
Or maybe, just maybe, Tesla saw past the slights.
Maybe he had so much faith in humanity that
he trusted we would one day be able to figure
out how to stop SCP-2700-Omega, and both universes
in the process.
No matter his reasoning, all we can do now
is place our hope in the SCP Foundation’s
top minds to find a solution.
But the clock is ticking.
Now go check out “SCP-1461 - House of the
Worm” and “SCP-1765 - Sisters” for terrifying
tales of anomalous science gone wrong!